-You know our first guest
tonight from his work
on "The Office"
and "Tom Clancy's Jack Ryan.
His latest film,
"A Quiet Place Part II,"
which he wrote and directed,
opens in theaters May 28th
Let's take a look.
[ Metal creaking ]
[ Fence clatters ]
[ Rope whirs, bottles clanking ]
♪♪♪♪
-Run.
[ Breathing heavily ]
♪♪♪♪
-Please welcome back to the show
and to the studio
our very good friend
John Krasinski.
[ Applause ]
Yeah! Whoo-hoo!
-Yeah!
Wow.
-It's a lot.
-How you doing?
-So good to see you.
Oh, physical contact.
-Physical contact.
This is a lot.
-Hey, everybody.
-This is...
-Look at that guy.
-They're all here -- 1, 4...
-So silhouetted.
There's so many people.
-This is the definition of
unfinished business, my friend
-I mean, this is full circle
-You're our first guest,
one that I've given a hug to
since, you know, bad times
First guest we're letting sit --
-On camera.
You're hugging people
like crazy on the street.
-Oh, my God, everywhere --
in public,
in streets, in stores.
You are the first guest
we're letting sit in this chai
because you were our last --
-It's true.
-You were supposed to be -
You are the last guest
that canceled on us before we --
-Well, that's debatable.
That's debatable.
-It was March 12th.
-I got the, "Get in the car,
get out of the car, get in
the car, get out of the car.
-It was the way --
I mean, we were sort of --
I think we knew it was real,
because we know you to be
a solid guy who would neve
shirk your commitments.
And the fact that you said
"Hey, I don't think
I should come,"
we -- Shoemaker and I
looked at each other and said,
"Well, I think
we got to get out of here, too
if Krasinski's out."
[ Laughter ]
-"Did Jack Ryan just say
we gotta get out of here?"
-Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
Everybody just starts...
-You did. You gave us
one of those Jack Ryan board
with the yarn going over
to different pictures.
-Exactly! Exactly.
Yeah.
That's what I was doing.
-The other trippy thing is
not only did you cancel
March 12th of last year --
and, again,
I want to keep saying
you canceled.
-Yeah, it's really subliminal,
but it's really working.
I'm feeling worse...
-And I don't want to put thi
on you, but you canceled,
and then everything went south
-[ Laughing ]
-I don't know
if you're the first --
-I think the next day,
the NBA went.
They heard I canceled,
and they were like,
"Oh, my God.
We're out."
-The crazy thing is, you're here
promoting the same movie.
-[ Laughing ] Yes.
I mean, that's really
the trippiest part.
-It's Part 2.2.
So, this is a full 14 months
since you were
supposed to release it.
-Yeah, it's the most
bizarre thing to make a movi
and then not put it out,
but, clearly, the world
was going through somethin
more bizarre
than not putting out a movie
so there was very little emotion
in making the decision
to not come to this show.
Now, making the decision to hold
the movie was a bigger deal,
but not coming to this was easy.
-Yeah.
I was like, "Yeah. Easy."
[ Laughter ]
-But the other thing
that must have been nice is,
if it had been the first
"Quiet Place" --
I was thinking about this --
I feel as though,
'cause you had this idea
that was very novel,
and no one had seen
a horror movie like that,
and I think any time
you have material
that you have to hold,
in the back of your head,
you're thinking,
"What if someone else
comes up with this idea
while I have it done?"
-Yes.
-So at least it was a sequel
You'd already sort of
planted the flag.
-That's true, yeah.
-Yeah.
The weird part was,
because people knew the movie,
I started getting texts,
one of which from Maya Rudolph
It was about three months
into the quarantine,
and she goes,
"All right, I get it.
We have had enough.
When are the creatures coming?
I was like, "No, no,
this isn't the movie!"
She's like, "This is the movie
This is it," so...
-Were any friends asking,
in this desperate year,
where people were running ou
of things to watch,
were they saying,
"I know it's done.
Give me the movie"?
-Paul.
Maya's man,
Paul Thomas Anderson,
who is also my filmmaking hero
literally said exactly that.
He was like,
"No, I totally get it.
It's a tough decision.
Do you have a print of it?
Can you just send it over?
[ Laughter ]
And I did.
-You did?
Well, that's good.
There are certain people
you can't hold the line on
-Yeah, no, totally.
-And I think --
-He's also one of those people
when you call the studio,
and you're like, "Can he --"
they're like, "Yep! Yes! Yes!"
And you're like,
"I haven't even told you
what he wants yet,"
and they're like,
"We already sent it.
We sent him churros,
we sent him popcorn."
Like, "No, he wants the movie.
He wants the movie."
[ Laughter ]
-You're actually --
You know, this is obviousl
a different time, as well.
I think, had you had the
premiere of "Quiet Place II"
-We did, two days before
I think I canceled --
Oh, my God.
You did it -- you incepted me.
[ Laughter ]
-You canceled.
-You incepted me!
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
You spun us out.
-Yeah.
-It wasn't until like May
that we could like say --
-Had I not canceled,
you would've been doing the show
all summer long.
-Absolutely.
-I would have insisted
on audiences.
But you are now, because
you're not doing a premiere --
you already did it...
-Yep.
-...you're going
theater to theater,
which is a pretty cool thing
-Well, this is my thing is
we're so excited to be
one of the first movies back
And I feel almost
a responsibility --
I had an emotional connectio
to it because I was
one of the last movies to almost
make it to the starting line
Then I thought I'd bookend it.
Not that anybody else cares, but
I think it's kind of special
-[ Laughs ] Right.
-But if you're a fan
of the movie, I wanted to
bookend the pandemic for you
And I think the other thing fo
me is, it's not about our movie.
Sure, we hope you come
see our movie,
but at this point in time,
it's about movies in general
It's just about getting back
to the theater,
getting back to being together
which we're going to be
doing here soon, I'm sure.
And I think at the end
of the day, it's something -
So we're going
to all these theaters.
I've been to Cleveland,
New York, Miami.
We're going to other
secret locations.
And it's been awesome.
I mean, just to get there
and see all these people
who working at the theaters,
who have been hurting a bit,
and we're --
you know, it's really nice
to celebrate them
and bring them back.
-This is a family affair.
Your wife, Emily,
is in the film.
You appear in a flashback.
-I do.
Spoiler alert. Great.
-You die in the first one.
-What the hell, man?
[ Laughter ]
-Look, I'm gonna say --
Here's why I said that.
If people went a whole pandemi
and didn't watch the first one
when they literally were
watching everything...
-You're right, yeah.
-...if you didn't watch
"A Quiet Place" this year,
you're never gonna watch it.
-That's true.
-But maybe if there's people
who desperately don't like you
and want to see you die,
and now they know.
-Wow.
-Well, then I'm saying --
-Guys, this turned negative.
This got da-- It was, like
funny dark and then really dark.
-You canceled on us!
-I'm actually scared.
-You canceled on us.
-Mike, come on, man.
[ Laughter ]
How is it -- I mean,
we've talked about it before
but, you know, it's obviousl
a very intense scene.
This is now --
I'm getting dangerously close.
I don't want
to give anything away.
But how do you direct --
Because this is a very --
This is one of those shots
that's very complicated,
and it seems very involved
I'm assuming it's somethin
you have to rehearse
for a fair amount of time.
Like, how do you direct --
-Are you talking about
Emily's car scene?
-Yeah.
-So, the car scene that
I think is in the trailer,
that was definitely
the hardest thing to shoot
but probably my proudest momen
as a director.
It's one of those things
where every single crew member
put their stamp
and their fingerprints on it
but we planned it for six weeks.
We rehearsed it with stunt
for three weeks,
and then, on the day,
I said to Emily,
"Do you want to rehearse one?"
She said, "No. You know what
I just want to experience it
organically,"
and I said, "Oh, great."
So everything in that shot
is actually happening to her
She's hitting human beings -
that are stunt people --
there's a lot of cars almost
hitting her -- by stunt people
And there's a bus
actually coming at her
at 45 miles an hour.
And I don't think
she knew that part.
[ Laughter ]
So as I close the door,
she's like, "I just want t
experience it organically,
and I went, "Okay, great."
And I shut it,
and I went to the --
I saw the camera crew go,
"I don't -- I don't --"
And I was like, "Let's do it!"
And they're like,
"Are you sure?"
And I was like, "Did I just pu
my marriage on the line?"
And then the car took off.
And I was like, "Wait!"
and we were rolling.
-I mean, she must be happy
with the way it turned out
though, right?
-Very.
-I mean, it seems like
her instincts were very good
to react to in real time.
-Yeah.
It was terrifying.
-It was very, very scary.
But the cool thing is,
it's a car we build
a pod on top, so the guy on to
is actually a stunt driver
And I remember Emily said
she turned to the guy,
and he said, "You okay?"
and she said,
"Well, actually, my life
is technically in your hands,"
and he went, "Don't worry,
Ms. Emily -- I'm the best.
And she went, "Okay. That
actually made me feel great.
That makes me feel really good."
-I would say that's
every stuntman I've ever met
[ Laughter ]
There's no stuntman rolls in
he's like, "I'm the 'C' choice."
[ Laughter ]
-"I'll be honest with you,
Ms. Emily, I am mediocre."
[ Laughter ]
"Wait. What?"
-"A few guys fell out
for me to get this job."
[ Laughter ]
"I blew it.
I had my meeting with John
Blew it pretty hard.
-"I'll be honest.
I just arrived
on that there bus, so..."
[ Laughter ]
-But it really is --
I think it is a lovely bookend
and I want to congratulate you
for staying the course.
-Thank you.
This is a lovely bookend.
It's so nice to see you.
-It is.
-Congrats, by the way,
since the time I was suppose
to see you, that you canceled,
and then now,
congrats again on doing "SNL."
-Thank very much.
That is a life goal
of all life goals.
-Yeah.
-And it was amazing
to actually see it happen.
Everybody was like,
"We're sorry that you had
to do it during COVID."
I was like, "This is amazing!"
There was actually something
really special about doing i
during that whole time.
-It was amazing
to watch the show
and how they adapted this year
and it was really nice
to see you do it.
And, buddy, thank you so muc
for being here.
-Absolutely.
So good to see you.
-We're gonna touch again!
Human hands!
-Yes!
Anybody have Purell?
[ Laughter ]
-"The Quiet Place Part II"
opens in theaters Friday,
or another pandemic will happen.
We'll be right back.
[ Laughter ]
Well, I'm just saying.